it's been about a week since we heard
about the spiderman sony disney deal and
although the final result of that deal
may seem like it is set in stone and
spider-man is no longer in the MCU we
have new reports that say there is still
hope what's going on everybody it's
Warren and this is a really big deal to
a lot of people the vast majority of
people want to see Spidey stay in the
MCU but sadly the last thing that we
heard was that the deal fell through and
spider-man is going to stay with Sony no
longer being a part of the MCU and then
Kevin Feige released an official
statement during an interview with
Entertainment Weekly and it really
seemed like spider-man was done he said
I'm feeling about spider-man gratitude
and joy we got to make five films within
the MCU with spider-man two standalone
films and three with the Avengers it was
a dream that I never thought would
happen it was never meant to last
forever we knew there was a finite
amount of time that we'd be able to do
this and we told the story we wanted to
tell and to always be thankful for that
so we thought things were officially
done but now we have a new report that
says Disney and Sony are still possibly
working out a deal
so there still could be hope for
spider-man in the MCU and we'll talk
about everything that has happened in
this video real quick if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like the
video and comment with your favorite
superhero or villain I'm doing a
giveaway and picking a winner at 500,000
subscribers
hopefully happening within the next
couple of weeks so this report comes
from when Tom Holland attended Keystone
comic-con in Philadelphia now obviously
going into Keystone Comicon everybody
was wondering what exactly is going to
happen with spider-man is he going to
stay in the MCU or is he going to go to
what Sony calls the spider-verse of
course that was really the only question
on people's mind but according to the
people who attended Keystone comic-con
they were specifically told not to ask
any questions about the sony disney deal
according to the report Keystone
comic-con told the 2000 people in the
room to avoid talking about Sony and
Disney split because it might mess up
any contract discussions that will be
announced within the next few days so
according to this report Sony and Disney
are still trying to work out a deal
which makes perfect sense Marvel and
Disney obviously won
spider-man to stay in the MCU and
there's not really a timeline to
completing this deal they don't need to
complete it by a certain time the only
thing they really need to worry about is
spider-man 3
and right now that kind of seems to be
up in the air anyway so it's not like
they have to start shooting that anytime
soon and according to this report the
deal is still alive and there is still a
chance that spider-man could stay in the
MCU now of course even though Keystone
told the audience not to ask any
questions about the deal that's the
first thing that they asked when Tom
Holland got on stage and his answer
according to the fans in attendance
sounded very scripted meaning it sounded
like something Sony and Disney told him
to say until a deal was completely
finalized which again is a sign that the
Disney Sony deal is still happening
they're still trying to work out a deal
but Tom Holland did say that it is not
the end for him playing spider-man
he said there's definitely more to come
I'm just really excited for everything
it's only going to get bigger and better
it's pretty crazy so no matter what
happens it's not the end for Tom Holland
playing spider-man and we thought that
the deal was done and Tom Holland was
going to continue to play spider-man but
only with Sony but now according to this
report it seems like Sony and Disney are
still trying to work something out for
spider-man to stay in the MCU so let me
know what you think about this let me
know what you think about Keystone
comic-con telling their audience not to
ask anything because it could interrupt
a discussion of a deal and I want you to
tell me in the comments will you still
watch spider-man if he is no longer a
part of the MCU be sure to comment below
with your thoughts and again be sure to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
do not forget to follow me on Twitter
and Instagram and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof